okay support for the impeachment and
removal of Donald Trump has exploded and
support for the impeachment inquiry has
nearly tripled even among Republicans
over the last couple of weeks this is
not good news for Donald Trump Donald
Trump has been touting these
cartoonishly high approval ratings from
Republicans sometimes Trump will tweet
Republican 95% support thank you and
maybe that's true in some poll I mean I
haven't seen it
maybe Rasmussen has Trump at 95%
approval among Republicans that's not
the data that I've been seeing most of
the polls I've looked at have Trump's
Republican approval somewhere between
the high 70s and around 80 and what that
means is that there are one out of five
Republicans that do not approve of the
job that Donald Trump is doing this gets
us to more specifically assessing
support for the impeachment of the
president in the first week that week
between the start of the Ukraine Fiasco
going public and the few days after the
impeachment inquiry was announced
support for impeaching and removing
Trump went from 36 percent to 43 percent
that was an increase of about 20 percent
another week has gone by and support has
increased even more the questions in
this latest data are a little bit
different but most importantly support
for the impeachment inquiry has exploded
among all Democrats Republicans and
independents and it is growing in
parallel across party lines this is very
important and it's important because
Donald Trump needs that Republican
electorate to win re-election in 2020
so first 49% in a Washington Post Shar
school poll want the house to call for
the removal of Donald Trump 49% of
Americans 58 percent of Americans say
that the impeachment inquiry is correct
that it is the right thing to do but
maybe the single most notable number to
come out of this new poll is that the
move towards impeachment has happened
across party lines Democratic support
for the inquiry is up 25
points independent support for the
inquiry is up 20 points and Republican
support for the inquiry is up 21 points
thirty percent of Republicans now
support the impeachment inquiry that
Democrats are trying to carry out but
does this matter right I mean why do we
care in the end if three out of ten
Republicans support the inquiry because
the Republican Senate is very unlikely
to vote to convict the reason we care is
that the whole point of this is to get
people not to vote for Trump in 2020 and
I'm using very precise language there
now I know that there are some people in
my audience holding out hope that the
impeachment inquiry could lead to Donald
Trump's removal because Republicans in
the Senate will vote to convict I see it
as incredibly unlikely but anything is
possible the much more realistic outcome
is that the success of the impeachment
inquiry depends on influencing public
opinion when we look at public opinion
you see that in two weeks in two weeks
Republican support for the impeachment
inquiry has effectively tripled from
around 10 percent 11 12 maybe it was to
30 percent this does not bode well for
Donald Trump now a reasonably skeptical
observer of this would ask the question
if you're a Republican and you support
the inquiry does that mean you're gonna
vote for a Democrat in November of 2020
and that's a very good question to ask
and the answer is of course not
you are not necessarily or even likely
to vote for a Democrat in November of
2020 if you are a Republican who merely
thinks that the inquiry is warranted but
you might stay home and that alone could
be good enough to pull Trump out of the
White House assuming that we on the Left
get our base out as well in the last two
weeks we've seen Republican impeachment
inquiry support triple we have seen
triple 3 we've seen prominent
Republicans start to turn on Trump we've
seen loony Lindsey Graham and Moscow
Mitch McConnell albeit not over the
Ukraine stuff but over the serious stuff
start to sort of part ways with Donald
trumpet to some degree we are seeing the
right-wing media like FoxNews embroiled
in what I described earlier this week or
last week as an internal cannibalistic
battle over whether or not they will be
on the Trump train in 2020 and meanwhile
Trump has gone out after courting
Ukraine in a private phone call and
courted the Chinese for political dirt
on Joe Biden after the impeachment
inquiry was launched just imagine when
you look at what has taken place over
the last two weeks just imagine what
could happen between today and the next
democratic debate which is in a week
unprecedented circumstances Donald Trump
drawing a line in the sand saying he
will not participate in the impeachment
inquiry whose support has now tripled
tripled among Republicans stunning stuff
I want to hear from you what do you
think is going to be the next shoe to
drop make sure you are commenting if
you're watching on YouTube make sure to
send me a tweet on Twitter at D Pakman
and while you're there follow the David
Pakman show on Twitter at David Pakman
show we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this I am thrilled to
tell you that today's episode is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman Blink astiz a really unique
service for your phone tablet and web
browser and it is incredibly useful for
people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks i'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a 7 day
free trial by going to blink accom slash
Pakman if you're watching on YouTube
I've put a link
the description I have listened to
blinka spokes about economics about
political science about history about
science so many interesting things and
after the free trial if you like it you
can continue enjoying thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about 5 bucks a
month go to blink is calm slash Pakman
that's be Li NK is t.com /pa k ma n